Now for this one I'm going to show you how\h
to wear the hakama.
This is not the "traditional" way.\h\h
It's not like there is any "traditional" way to\hbe honest, when you think about the history of the thing and the way we wear it with a judo\hkeikogi.
So I'm going to show you my way to wear it,
which i find both easy and convenient.
So you take it\hfrom the front, like this, and the first thing you,
is that of course, you step one leg at the time\hin the hakama.
So one leg, and the other leg.
Then, you place the hakama like this.
Place your belt\hunder the bone of your hips like this.
It should be way below your belly button, under the bones\h
of your hips.
That's for males by the way. Females may wear it differently but obviously\hI'm showing it to you to you the way I wear it.
OK, so the belt is kind of going a bit down\hlike this, a little bit higher above your buttocks.
If you've got a belly of course it starts to fall\hnaturally down so that's good.
But even if you\h\hdon't have a belly make sure you have that sort of that shape.
Then you take the hakama front like this\hand you place it right above the belt.
Here.
So that\hpart here, which is the front strap of the hakama falls\hright above your obi, your belt here.
Then you're\hgoing to wrap it around above your belt.
At the back,\hyou're going to cross here you cross here,
which makes the straps of the hakama end up\hunder your belt.
You make them all go all\hthe way around like this.
What I like to do\h\his to make sure that my obi,
that I showed\hyou how to tie in the previous video,
stays on top like this.
Again not necessarily\h"traditional" or anything...
Don't look\h\hfor too much meaning inside that because there is\h
none, actually.
It's just the way that I prefer\hto do it.
So those two straps from the belt are\habove like this.
This is at the front like this\h\h
And then you're going to make one first knot\hunder the obi, here.
Like this, under the obi.\h
Tie it, and go around.
When you go around,\hit still stays under the belt like this.
You go around under.
And then when you're\hdone you make a knot like this.
One,
and you make one more at the top here,
two, just\ha simple knot two simple knots, like this.
What I like to do when I'm done with this,
I like to place those straps, to roll them inside here.
Over there, one, and two.
Not under the belt but under the\hstraps of the hakama.
So here it's nice and\htight.
Then I'm going to take the back,
lift up the back like this.
Place the koshiita, here on the back, at the top of the belt.
Here, like so.
And then I'm gonna send\hthis inside the belt.
So i'm gonna grab inside the\hbelt...
You can actually stand it also under those\hstraps here if you prefer.
It doesn't matter which\hone you do.
So I'll place it under the straps here.
Other the side, same, over here.
And then this\his going to fall under the whole\hbelt, here.
So you're going to be making your\hknot here, under this one
So here is your\hbelt here,
Belt,
the first knot that we did with the\hhakama here,
the second knot goes under.
One knot,
a second knot on top, to tighten it.
OK.
Tighten this and then just roll them in the\h\hhakama straps like you did before with\hthe other strap ends.
Here, it's nice and tight.
You can practice, it's not going to go down and it's\hnot going to going to open,
because you've made\h\hsure that you tied it twice like this.
It's kind of flat like this so it looks okay.
I'm not doing the sort of a butterfly, "traditional" knot,
on purpose because I find this is more\hresilient when you practice,
and\hit's also also quicker to do.